but what about the responsibilities that
a filmmaker has to their subject you
know it's such a touchy thing to want to
make a film about someone and then if
that person does say yes you're worried
how will they perceive themselves you
know what sort of allegiance do you have
to that subject so that you cut it
together in a way that they're happy
with but also that you're happy with
that's a good question I mean you know
you want your art when it comes down to
it to not be this sort of democratic
process you don't want to be people
pleasing when you're trying to you know
share this feeling or this this urge
that's kind of just on your heart you
know and there are times like with my
last film where where you do have an
allegiance you build an allegiance to
somebody and you want to do them justice
and you don't want them to make you
don't want to make them look bad but
sometimes making them look at--look bad
is good for the story and so there's the
the that struggle does kind of come up
often and I guess what to do about that
I mean I think in the end what we chose
to do with the last film anyway I think
it varies with film the film's subject
to subject was do justice to the story
if we have to put them in kind of a bad
light or negative light we'll do so but
not to the extent that we're gonna ruin
their character or something you know
and and and do them an injustice for
example like him unless Sue's there
scenes of Jos where main character
falling asleep in his cab as he's
waiting for customers to come up to his
calves he's waiting in a train station
and you know probably not a very good
way to represent a cab driver the guy
that's constantly falling asleep you
know you want to feel like you know
you're relatively safe when someone's
driving around town and so we were kind
of worried about those kinds of things
we want to portray him as this is this
guy was just kind of sleeping on the job
all the time and you know he depends on
this income it's very important to him
we don't
do that to him so you know I think we
did it kind of tasteful in the film we
we didn't shoot him falling asleep of
the wheel entirely you know like there's
a couple shots of him kind of looking
sleepy but we were very careful not to
portray him in a certain light that
would affect his ability to make a
living for him and his family so yeah I
don't know I think he can had to
case-by-case basis I think yeah yeah I
remember those scenes I think he did the
tastefully well because it fit in with
the fact that he was working two jobs I
didn't feel just how exhausting it a
sense of duty to his family yeah and and
the chance to be in America Simon yeah
yeah and we didn't want to go too far on
that just enough to kind of like right
tell the story yeah
you